was ist denn deine service corp zu 39
briten höhe
gebt euch das mal der wirt 39 blöcke
hoch der geht bis da oben halten du
kleiner als großer ist das geil
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft galaxy auf dem galaxy server
ich nehme die folge gerade direkt im
anschluss an die letzte folge auf die
ihr gesehen habt weil ich in dieser
folge wieder einiges schaffen möchte und
zwar möchte ich mein brachiosaurus mache
ich einen neuen stall für den ich glaube
nicht dass die sich nachher irgendwie
kaputt flaschen oder so wollte ich
schlüpfen lassen
direkt neben dem kollegen hier der mich
mittlerweile irgendwie hast ich weiß
nicht warum ich habe ihn einmal
geschlagen um zu testen ob er mich mag
vielleicht hat ihm das nicht so toll
gefallen der kollege paddington also
dass da recht ist paddington und für den
brachiosaurus ich weiß ich dass es soll
ach das ist so ein großes teil scheiße
mann der überhaupt platz findet ich habe
echt bedenken nicht dass er gar keinen
platz findet ich glaube ich mache dem
erstmals ein schmales teil also
irgendwie nur so breit aber dafür dann
halt relativ hoch das wäre schön wenn
man so eine mining turtle hätte dann
könnte man das ganze so ein bisschen
dann könnte man das selbst nicht alles
machen aber ich kann ihnen schon mal
hierhin setzen dass der sich schon mal
aus blüte und ich hoffe dann dass der
wenigstens gezähmt ist also wenn ich am
terex habe dann ist das natürlich klar
dass der so ein bisschen sonne guckt
durch radler oder ich mache dieses kino
gehege irgendwie besser
ich weiß ja nie vergisst ich lasse ihn
einfach kurz hieraus schlüpfen oder
leider kann er nicht so viel kaputt
machen oder ich mach das mal ganz kurz
hierzu effekt sondern sitzt denn hier
drauf 0
hawking aging nie wie lange dauert das
alter wenngleich ihm wieder ein steht
oder so oder wenn das immer bei null
bleibt dann gehen wir vielleicht
irgendwann steht dann das wird auf
keinen fall mehr dieser folge passieren
wie lange braucht man so einen scheiß
brachiosaurus ist er so heftig ich guck
mal ganz kurz im internet wartet so hier
velociraptor habe ich hier da habe ich
hier nämlich training reduziert das
table dancing with the same way als oder
table prehistoric rappt als wegkamp
rating between two thumbs up to change
the place ist ein ranger blabla
wittenberger because clicking with your
hand mit meiner hand kann ich den rechts
klicken
bei aller ist ja gar nicht hängt aber
wie vitali ich den denn jetzt
weil es das traurig ich will dass du
mein dinosaurier wie ist es an themen
wie krieg der frist auf fleisch täter
oder nimmst du vielleicht auch irgendwie
erdbeeren oder so eine scheiße ich habe
ich keine ahnung wie ich den themen soll
das etwas krejcik riesige sache wenn ihr
jetzt noch einstellen da denken wir
immer noch 0
vielleicht kann er auch nicht unter dem
freien himmel landen nicht bei nacht das
kann auch sein dass es vielleicht nicht
bei nacht geht dann gehe ich mal ganz
kurz
die ich mal ganz kurz ach so ist man
zwei verschiedene jetzt voller gefragt
warum ich trotzdem in ein schaf
verwandelt werde wenn ich doch gar kein
wenn ich auf mich schon mal scharf
getötet habe wahrscheinlich einfach
verschiedene farben hatte das können wir
sicherlich trink mal ganz kurz einen
schluck
mal schauen wie es unsere neige geht ja
es lag ich am tag alle nacht war danach
ging es wohl nicht okay krass geil dann
geht vielleicht auch noch in dieser
folge es geht auf jeden fall in dieser
folge stark freut mich so was hat mir
dann noch alles wir hatten hatte ich
nicht noch ein lino ich glaub von
paladin ursache ein glück ich hatte
religion und tablets und zwar fragt ihr
euch was bringen diese stand er jetzt
eigentlich eher ich hab's mittlerweile
herausgefunden ich kann damit supertolle
bildchen an die wand klatschen fast
genau wie das bringt weiß ich nicht aber
ich wollte ja unten sollen die nur raum
machen und dann packten alle die nur
sachen hin also auch dieses tor und
tablets ich habe es mal ganz kurze wie
das ist ob ich das hier alles noch bauen
ob ich das überhaupt bauen von 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 23 45 dann geht hier so eine
treppe nach unten
ich hoffe mal dass ich das alles
umsetzen kann so wie hoch mache ich dann
den raum
ich habe mal ganz kurz darauf wieder
meinem dino hier geht die low lino denen
ich glaube die nulllinie
das ist total die schulname 123456 mal
die deckenhöhe ist jetzt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 macht das mal zehn blöcke erstmal
ich hoffe jetzt nicht dass ich jetzt
irgendwie auf der höhe bin wo ich dann
gleich wirklich einfach unten wieder bin
ich noch zehn blöcke nicht oder so dass
man sich jetzt guck ich mal hier eben
das ist dass sie wieder in täglicher
touren bisher hier sind so aus der
agentur mehr gut da kommt dann quasi
mein teilen der ganze keller geht am
besten kann kann man ja so lassen ob der
bogen den verzauberten bogenberger seien
da noch etwas hätte ich jetzt nein ich
vollidiot jetzt ist er auch nicht themen
aber das war gut dass ich dich da
drinnen gemacht habe aber kommt sogar
hut auf den lippen
ich weiß nicht wer mein brachiosaurus
der das ist eigentlich viel mehr linken
das ist eigentlich wirklich viel mehr in
paddington das ist doch eigentlich ich
will ich will mir einmal kann ich den
reiten
ich gehe mal ganz kurz aus einem mord
aus den reifen ich möchte auf jeden fall
ein foto mit ihm machen gleich auf
twitter posten war da habe ich nicht
doch irgendwie was anderes habe ich
nicht noch etwas cooles mit pickerl
einfach ein trial aufgekommen war bin
ich froh dass ich gerade dieses wirklich
dieses kapitel über diese skp sondern
uns immer bewusst und aus es krachte
mich so an du denkst du ja ok fick dich
dort kommt er jetzt hier ja das ist
einfach mal hin
war das richtig foto gehen jetzt macht
er noch hier so ein bisschen cooler typ
gefällt mir irgendwie rechtsklick nicht
allerdings machen die via antenne wie
kann ich ihnen jetzt themen beschäftigen
wie nur noch mit dsl das ist echt
richtig schön gefällt mir gerade so
brach hier einfach brachiosaurus sarah
blaser herbig ist eine chance dem motto
think we can be extremely zu 39 briten
höhe
gebt euch das mal der wirt 39 blöcke
hoch da geht es da oben alter pennington
du kleiner als großer ist das geil
brothers und portishead dem ausfall war
ein fehler unterlief blogs between two
blogs auf ei so wenn ich ihn wieder
haben müssen die auf augenhöhe sein herz
bildet ist roy ellis traktoren toller
den hck der block i want to fans beim
rivalen remember to date die fenster es
scheiße ich muss quasi den zaun so hoch
bauen wieder ist
scheiße dann setze ich den evo nach
unten oder so oder wirklich immer dino
keller dann und dann eingebaut mit
zahlen
aber ich kann ihr keinen dino keller
machen ich muss ja oft da oben drauf
sein aber hier sind tamron soll diese
ganzen arschlöcher man dass die sich
alle zu mir das wirklich richtig auf ob
die health of modern art player oder
handy aber das soll der camcorder
dritter stick with the droid life wanted
reseller apple sogar cookies and certain
age okay gut ich war nicht in der nähe
das heißt er ist nicht tätig das ist ein
bisschen scheiße aus der licht-test ich
mache dem trotzdem mal ich mag ihn
trotzdem das ist paddington hass hat er
hier eigentlich schon irgendwas aus der
kiste gefressen kleiner sack ich hoffe
so ich mache mir einfach noch eine kiste
hier grade ich sehe total wild aus grad
in face kann weil man ganz klar
irgendwie die sind wieder viel zu lang
da muss ja auf jeden fall mal zum
friseur
ich wollte mir eine kette machen da ich
aber noch ganz viel
neben die kiste für den kollegen
was wusste hin ohne spaß es ist doch
verflucht
das kann nicht sein der ist einfach
abgehauen
er kann auch nicht weg sein was ist denn
wenn ich mich mal vielleicht war gerade
nacht wird oder wie oder woran liegt das
jetzt wieder
ich gehe ganz kurz wieder schlaf nicht
dass jetzt das kann auch nicht sein
wieso ist der weg ist der andere noch
daher der anderes ob da wir können nicht
über 90 grad es wird nicht mal leid wie
kann das sein wie sie ist jetzt weg ich
verstehe diese die noten nicht bei mir
geht alles schief was schief gehen kann
wo ist er hin dann muss er dann hier
unten evo rumlaufen
da war gerade ein dino und der ist jetzt
einfach weg ist er gestorben oder was
ich kann
ich verstehe das nicht kennt sich
irgendwer aus mit dieser die
modifikation bitte helft mir
das kann doch nicht sein dass das da so
eine scheiße ist das kann echt nicht
sein denn kinos einfach weg da mache ich
mir extra so ein tolles gegen elvis und
dann haut er einfach ab so brach los ist
der größte dinosaurier letzten spiele
der haut einfach ab dieses arschloch
viel man wie ich das kolleg das klappt
alles nicht so wie ich das will ich
glaub ich lese mich einfach mal die tage
noch gegen andere modifikationen 81 auch
noch an pflanzen habe ich extra so
mitgenommen
zwei stück stark wo sie auf jeden fall
ein bisschen sand noch holen habe ich
nicht sagen ich hab doch ivo sanader
ich sollte jetzt mal ganz kurz in den
letzten minuten zum inventar das hier
ist auch schon fast alles voll es ist
natürlich sehr sehr cool silicon de das
kommt die andere kiste die strawberry
kann ich ja hier auch mal noch gar kein
platz mehr
sehr cool
beim plamper ich habe meine rüstung
nicht an den ball
das wäre blöd gewesen sich jetzt
irgendwas gemacht hatte so hier kommt
ihr mal alle rein
ganz so coole sachen holz ein ballyhoo
als rein
so here ich packe meine rolle da auch
rein so habe ich dann auch im moment so
die dgp da packe ich hier rein in meinem
wertvoll scheiß kiste hier kommt ihr
abitur zu es muss ja eh mitnehmen so was
kann ich denn noch ja von alles fressen
ich glaube gar nicht mal so viel
hier hätte ich noch nicht gehabt dass
ich den dinosaurier auch geben können
hier war übrigens im buch dank an alle
die mir das geschrieben haben ich habs
jetzt auch gelesen ich finde es ein
bisschen doof dass der hier nicht tamed
ist der hier warten aber ich habe dann
einfach geschlagen hier kommen im herz
an herz essen
kraus ich hab einfach erst gegessen
ja ich weiß nicht was das soll dieser
kleine menschen mit denen ich mag dich
doch aber du bist einfach an times ich
warte einfach bist du groß bist sondern
ich bin wirklich auf euch angewiesenen
kommentaren dass er da so ein bisschen
hilft wie genau ich das ganze wie ich
hier vorzugehen habe na ja gut ich weiß
nicht ob die nächste folge die ein
stunden folge sein wird oder irgendeine
danach oder irgendwie irgendwo
irgendwann mit auf jeden fall ein
stunden folge kommen und bitte schreib
mir viele tipps wie möglich und
vielleicht auch was zu tun kannst red
oder wenn irgendwelche videos dazu habt
schickt mir das alles weil ich wollte
mich dann auch mit tinkers construct
jetzt anfangen und das ist ja echt
scheiße dass dieser dino als einfach weg
ist
das bringt mir auf dass hier einfach
dass hier wirklich tim und sowohl das
ist ein bisschen traurig na ja gut er
muss jetzt mal mit leben dass dieser die
nur einfach abgehauen das hat mich wohl
nicht aber auch an teilt also freier
wildbahn
es wird nacht ich dir vom server wenn es
euch trotzdem gefallen hat last mag ich
da wirklich ganz viele tipps in die
kommentare und oder per mail
und schau ist traurig